c'est le principe de l'offre et de la
demande en fait c'est une demande au
départ quand les gens ont dit on a envie
de vous voir
ça faisait ça faisait déjà un moment
oui mais en fait nous on n'a jamais de
problème avec ça c'est vrai que aussi on
a quand même depuis plusieurs plusieurs
années une on assume totalement avoir
une sexualité assumée et libre on va au
club naturiste du cap d'Agde de tous les
ans depuis des années on a proposé à TF1
ils ont dit que c'était pas dans la
thématique de punition et vous êtes
échangiste ou pas
parce que au Cap d'Agde
au Cap d'Agde tu peux aller dans des
boîtes ou tu as des rapports avec ton
compagnon mais sans échanger
tu t'es arrivé quelqu'un tu repars avec
quelqu'un que mais bien sûr on a eu des
propositions
va commencer donc des propositions de
gens qui vous disent on a envie de vous
voir en train de me demander non ils
m'ont demandé
tout ça c'est des comptes en fait privé
pour voir voilà pour voir avec eux mais
oui effectivement pour des pour des
photos de charme ou des contenus alors
vous avez visité vous en avez parlé tous
les deux comment vous avez eu l'idée on
en a parlé tous les deux donc au départ
moi c'est moi qui ai pensé en premier et
Alex au départ était un peu mitigé et en
fait après ma vie oui vas-y fais-le
muscle toute seule donc moi par contre
je ne voulais pas le lancer là-dedans
toute seule et je lui ai dit non c'est
soit c'est une aventure qu'on fait
ensemble qu'on assume et en plus
voilà mais bon bref on aurait été un peu
enfin moi j'aurais pas pu j'aurais pas
pu faire ça toute seule et donc vous
avez et donc vous êtes dit on va le
faire est-ce que on vous a proposé tout
de suite beaucoup d'argent ou pas du
tout
dans les demandes de média privé on nous
propose des sommes assez intéressantes
quand même pour des contenus à deux
ouais Amandine et Alexandre
vous êtes fait beaucoup critiquer mes
chéries oui voilà ils ont dit voilà il y
a plein de gens qui disent oui c'est une
admissible oui
on voit lui ici
qu'est-ce que vous en dites ce que vous
avez 8 enfants on peut rappeler de
calage alors de 17 à 3 ans donc de 3 ans
le petit de trois ans
et quel âge
17 ans 10 ans 9 ans 8 ans 6 ans
comment vous l'avez
dit ça
le seul qui a accès finalement à
donc il vous a dit quoi et ben lui il
nous a dit
ça vous lui avez dit on lui a dit donc
voilà alors c'est vrai que moi j'ai
pensé depuis un petit moment j'en avais
fait part à Alex en fait j'ai une copine
donc donc je ne citerai pas le nom qui
est dans la téléréalité depuis très
longtemps qui est toujours à la télé à
l'heure actuelle et qui a une plateforme
sur mime qui m'avait donc déjà parlé de
ça et donc moi j'avais parlé à Alexandre
de le faire et lui il était pas trop
chaud au début il me disait ouais non je
sais pas mais on est encore en tournage
avec TF1 à l'époque donc c'est un peu
paradoxal sachant que TF1 n'avait même
pas voulu nous suivre au village
libertin du Cap d'Agde alors qu'on leur
avait suggéré parce que c'était le
courant
de nos vacances le
on a compris donc du coup on a un peu
laissé tomber et il y a quelques temps
je me suis dit mais moi j'avais envie en
fait de me lancer là-dedans parce qu'en
fait il y a une demande c'est ce que je
dis vraiment une demande
de voir en train de faire l'amour pas
que des photos enfin il y a vraiment de
tout hein
vous faites des photos faites des vidéos
comme un réseau social type Instagram
avec un mur de photos qui est payant
accessible par le biais d'un abonnement
qui coûte 10 euros par mois donc
on a accès à tout on accède toutes les
photos du mur après et les vidéos sont
rajoutés
et là par contre on a juste le prix en
fonction de la demande fonction de ce
qu'on nous demande de faire ah d'accord
parce qu'il vous demande genre
un peu comme au resto ils te disent
qu'est-ce que vous proposez comme media
privé d'ailleurs j'habite il a fait un
truc en copier-coller il copie et puis
il me la donnes et je l'envoie
c'est très très complet
quoi d'accord
et donc
comment c'est rémunéré à peu près
comment on sait c'est combien à peu près
ces vidéos là ça dépend ça peut aller de
ça va de quoi de 50 à 150 euros
60 à 150 € par vidéo en fait
les photos c'est à peu près une
vingtaine d'euros les photos les photos
un peu plus
on a commencé ça début décembre
on est très décomplexé de ce côté-là
on partage toujours à même de 3 ans on
partage nos contenus l'été de mon
village nature et cetera enfin c'est
vraiment notre truc et
puis ça concerne en fait
Alexandre et moi effectivement Léo notre
fils aîné qui a accès à Internet aux
réseaux sociaux etc on lui a posé la
question avant de se lancer là dedans et
s'il avait mis un véto là dessus on ne
l'aurait pas fait et nos enfants les
éducs dans une liberté d'esprit de
parole après ça va et moi je comprends
tout à fait vous le faites ça rapporte
beaucoup d'argent ça rapporte des sous
vous ne faites pas que par rapport
et c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous
fait plaisir on est en symbiose tous les
deux on est en osmose dans notre couple
on a retrouvé en plus une complicité
incroyable bah oui après 13 ans 8
enfants tu te doutes bien enfin tu vois
après 8 pouces par Tom enfin tu vois on
est hyper épanoui quoi
dans très longtemps
alors je n’êtes pas choqué pas du tout
d'abord je les adore ensuite ils ont
toujours été nature comme ça ils se
montent et moi je sais qu'il y a une
demande pour eux je la comprends tout à
fait et ils ont bien raison c'est
parfaitement légal c'est vraiment la
personne à la carte pour des gens qui
ont envie et si eux ont envie aussi
c'est un désir réciproque je ne vois pas
le problème du tout alors Guillaume
jeton toi tu es outré oui
alors je suis choqué je suis déçu parce
que je vous aimez bien dans l'émission
de TF1
Nancy je vous apprécie mais j'ai
l'impression malheureusement pour vous
vous êtes tombé dans un espèce
d'engrenage où vous êtes prêt à tout
pour qu'on s'intéresse à vous pour qu'on
parle de vous pour gagner de l'argent et
je voulais vous poser une question c'est
est-ce que vous avez des limites parce
que vous dites que vous êtes un couple
exclusif vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous parlez de l'offre et de la demande
si demain il y a une offre parce que là
c'est des stocks pour une nuit et j'ai
refusé il y a trois jours bien sûr
[Rires]
astronomique parce que vous faites que
ça quand même pour l'argent est-ce que
si demain la somme elle est vraiment
astronomique ici que vous changez la vie
est-ce que vous le feriez alors c'est
pas que pour l'argent déjà d'une part ce
qui c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous
rend heureux en fait on est heureux
ensemble on est heureux de donner du
bonheur aux gens parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on rend des gens heureux en
fait il y a pas de mal à se faire du
bien effectivement il y a un principe
qui est l'offre et la demande néanmoins
on a des limites on nous propose des
choses qui ne sont pas faisable pour
nous notamment l'échangisme et déjà tu
en fréquente le village du Cap d'Agde
depuis des années on n'a jamais pratiqué
l'échangisme malgré les nombreuses voilà
non non non on n'y a jamais été beaucoup
plus calme moi j'adore
mais non en fait moi mon mari personne
touche mon mari personne me touche à
part Lui et en fait voilà ça ça rentre
dans une case
que vous avez expliqué à Léo aussi ça ah
oui complètement mais Léo en fait c'est
ce que j'allais dire en fait nous on
éduque nos enfants dans un principe de
liberté de parole liberté de penser je
pense que la plupart des détracteurs
enfin plutôt des détractrices qui nous
qui nous harcèle tous les jours ce sont
des femmes des mers au foyer des mamans
qui elles je pense justement élève des
futurs harceleurs des enfants qui
harcèleront parce que quand on voit les
propos qui sont tenus en fait tout
dépend de l'éducation que tu reçois et
aussi dans le milieu dans lequel tu
évolues nous on est dans une dans une
ville qui est populaire nos enfants sont
dans une école publique qui est
populaire avec une mixité sociale
qui a beaucoup manqué sur vous et qui me
dit de sources sûr elles bougent
vraiment pas d'une oreille en tout cas
voilà donc vous voyez donc vous pas ma
mère euh bah oui elle bouge pas d'une
oreille donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
voilà donc c'est c'est donc tout ce que
dit Amandine
vous vous êtes choqués Béatrice oui
alors je suis pas Genève pas des
harceleurs
j'en ai deux ils sont petits 4 et 7 je
ne vous juge pas du tout pour le fait
que vous faites vous ayez pas si vous
aviez fait ça avant d'avoir l'émission
de télé on aurait pas pu le faire mais
là mais là mais tout s'arrête mais s'ils
sont pas connus
x avant ils auraient pu faire des trucs
comme ça des photos
voilà ça ça m'aurait pas choqué moi ce
qui me choque un petit peu c'est que
vous avez utilisé une émission familiale
quand elle a commencé l'émission elle
savait pas qu'ils allaient faire ça
c'est bien après bah oui bien sûr
j'arrive jamais à finir une phrase ils
ont utilisé toriété d'une émission
familiale qu'ils ont vendu à leur propre
enfant comme étant une émission
de le faire avec vous
donc
c'était sur le principe du volontariat
nos enfants qui j'en ai déjà parlé voilà
donc vous avez parlé des enfants qui
voulaient pas tourner
les enfants qui ont insulté d'être chez
moi
vous alliez faire ce genre de choses
après ils vont pouvoir utiliser
on n'est pas aux États-Unis si on se
calme non mais c'est vrai ici aussi on
se lave non mais je vais vous dire
quelque chose
mais pas du tout vous dites vous
démarrez la phrase vous dites vous dites
une bêtise je suis désolé
la notoriété
familiale en quoi c'est une bêtise
pourquoi vous dites une bêtise Béatrice
vous dites j'aurais dû le faire avant
mais avant il n'était pas connu ils
auraient pas perdu ils auraient plus
que ce genre de plantes ne sont pas
lucratifs quand on n'est pas tous ceux
qui vont acheter sa vidéo
parce que j'ai pas fini mon idée
calme-toi quand même Béatrice calme-toi
c'est bon c'est bon là qu'est-ce que je
voulais dire nous le débat sur les
enfants et que là je dis non parce que
vous êtes au travail vos enfants ils
sont avec vous vous travaillez là ils
sont vos gosses ils sont là ils sont là
ils vont sur Google librement nous je
sais pas on a contrôle parentale encore
écouter
des stories en sous-titres c'est un an
pour une crème minceur on me disait oh
là là les copains de ton fils Léo ça va
toi bah ouais tout va bien lui il s'en
bat les couilles on passe à autre chose
toujours ses enfants
on se parle souvent au téléphone
on est amis voilà et donc
on va le retrouver au Cap d'accepte
les chez l'être humain la bienveillance
heureusement elle est très sourcilleuse
à propos de ses enfants
les enfants mais quand je mets les pieds
à l'école crois-moi bien que ça se passe
pas à l'école si j'y vais aux enfants
encore une fois ils sont élevés dans une
liberté de parole et de moi je pense
chacun fait ce qu'il veut à l'école ils
ont tous un an d'écart donc c'est à dire
qu'ils sont tous ensemble aller chacun
fait ce qu'il veut un jour ma fille ma
fille de 6 ans s'est fait embêter dans
la cour quand même que j'en ai une autre
qui a 8 ans puis que c'est une mccueil
au féminin tu vois elle est de rentrer
elle a dit quoi je vais les défoncer sur
embêter ma sœur mais en fait il y a une
il y a une solidarité entre les frères
et sœurs et il y a vraiment quelque
chose qui fait que on est au courant de
tout les enseignants nous connaissent et
encore une fois comme j'expliquais tout
à l'heure nous on est dans une école qui
est très enfin qui est dans une ville
qui est très populaire donc en fait il y
a une mixité
nous on s'en fout tous les deux Alex ça
concerne Alex et moi on entend TF1 à
apporter atteinte à nos enfants c'est
pour ça qu'on a arrêté l'émission et
enfin n'était pas raccord avec nos
valeurs et ensuite ils disent ça durera
pas ce que vous faites ça durera pas
internet n'oublie rien ça durera
toujours là je vois 9 enfants 8 enfants
qui faisait pour 60 balles il se passe
les dégâts entre 60 et 200 euros
tu connais le sujet
vraiment vraiment
sa fille est à côté d'ici les 8 enfants
là tu pourras pas savoir quand ils
auront 10 12 13 ans
pour les aider
dans cette liberté
j'espère qu'elle va payer sa dette à la
société
elle a été condamnée elle s'est pas
présentée à la condamnation arrêtez
congélateur elle a pas été parce qu'elle
était à l'hôpital
maintenant il faut que tu payes ta tête
à la société et je te dis moi en tout
cas je ne ce sujet les enfants
ce sujet vous rentrez nerveux dès que
vous voyez une paire de baloches
aux enfants c'est tout
c'est quand sur Internet on voit
librement de la violence de la haine ici
on voit et vous mettez au même niveau la
sexualité vous ricanez vous cacher les
yeux et vous êtes énervé alors qu'en
fait tout ce que ici autour de la table
et tous dans le public en fait il faut
arrêter
mais nous nous montrons
rien là ce ne sont pas des gens
professionnels qui font ça ce sont
qui s'aiment c'est un couple qui s'aime
et qui fait une action
non mais moi si je me file
mais je vais pas aller diffuser
je cautionne pas fort par rapport aux
enfants mais j'ai entendu que les
enfants grandissent dans une éducation
très libre les enfants
voilà naturiste donc je suppose que les
enfants sont aussi avec pendant ils vont
pas non par contre au village libertin
il va que le soir que les enfants sont
couchés qui sont avec la nounou
naturistes oui
normal et nous le soir au village
naturiste qui a un peu en mode libertin
le soir vos enfants grandissent
là-dedans vous voulez vous les vous les
désinhiber sur ça et en même temps moi
j'ai juste envie de dire ça reste que de
l'amour entre deux paires j'aimerais
bien entendre un peu Alexandre parce que
Amandine tu parles beaucoup mais
Alexandre
Alexandre alors on voit sur les vidéos
sortir son zizi mais on le voit pas
alors Alexandre mon chéri non mais c'est
vrai parce qu'on sait que tu as un zizi
on sait pas que tu as une langue pour
l'instant
nos enfants en fait ils sont heureux en
fait voilà en fait c'est l'essentiel et
puis tant que on leur donne de l'amour
et puis surtout toi tu étais pas inquiet
pour tes enfants non pas du tout non
quand il y a des gens qui te jugent tu
as envie de leur dire quoi
tu peux dire ce que tu veux ici
apaisez-vous non en fait rien en fait je
m'en fous complètement
notre famille voilà nous en fait tant
qu'on est heureux c'est l'essentiel
pensez qu'à vous vous pensez pas nos
enfants de mes enfants
mes enfants sont heureux dans 10 ans
au collège
parce que tu dis chacun ce qu'il veut
non Cyril à partir de responsabilité
qui va sortir le 29 qui va montrer une
immersion dans notre journée
entre notre vie de parents et notre vie
professionnelle un travail
comment le reportage
c'est quoi
en fait
Jerem là qui va sortir sur Youtube
et c'est quoi le comment s'appelle
mythomi raisin
je sais pas je sais pas quel nom il va
lui remettre mais en fait il va lui
mettre
mais en fait ça monte en fait on était
de très bons parents en fait
défoncez
la journée et le soir une fois que les
enfants sont au lit ou à l'école
claporter sur ma clé voilà parce qu'on a
à faire ce qu'on a envie de faire et ce
qui nous épanouit et on lance un bien et
l'argent
je suis pas choqué par le contenu donc
j'ai vu le fameux contenu une vidéo qui
a été supprimé d'ailleurs en tout cas je
pense qu'en fait
le porno a toujours existé il existera
toujours moi je suis pas je suis pas
choqué par ça de la même manière j'ai
pas juger la manière dont vous voulez ou
vous pouvez gagner de l'argent vous êtes
passé des miches aux boules bon pourquoi
pas moi ça me choque pas
en revanche moi je suis trop vite moi
mais moi je suis complètement sur la
même ligne que Béatrice qui était très
claire et Raymond qui était très clair
aussi et tu dis ça parce que je les ai
arrêtés c'est pas la peine non
si vous voulez c'est que vous êtes
passés donc de famille nombreux à le
Journal du Hard donc une certaine
manière vous instrumentalisez pas du
tout vous utilisez votre notoriété pour
vendre des vidéos pornos on est alors le
mal est où le mal est que on a on était
déjà dans
une liberté sexuelle il y a des victimes
dans ta vie vous êtes il y a des
victimes collatérales forcément parce
que même si
vous en occupez très bien si vous êtes
les meilleurs les meilleurs parents du
monde très bien vous savez très bien
fait grève
[Rires]
Amandine je vous trouvez charmante je
pense que vous allez très très très mal
ah non je sais très bien
psychologie donc à mon avis que vous
allez
on est en train de faire
attention
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
j'ai une émission à gérer quand vous
animerez une émission
vous avez la sensation
elle vous appellera et ben non j'espère
pas j'ai vendu consultation j'espère
prenez le temps j'espère que j'aurais
tant pis j'avais envie qu'elle vous pose
je suis mariée
j'ai envie de laisser le mot de la fin
Alexandre vas-y mon amour
[Rires]
oh allez oui alors
c'est peut-être parce qu'il habite à
côté de Chatou euh
non j'ai toujours amené comme ça ça fait
depuis qu'on est au début
[Applaudissements]
ils sont complètement fou
tu rends fou les gens toi Alexandre avec
ton zizi toi non mais je te jure
que l'américaine on dirait qu'elle avait
un burger non mais sans déconner c'est
quoi ça l'autre lui on dirait qu'il
avait un peu votre vitesse Éric il est
dans son canard
fais pas l'amour dans cette salle
devant nous en salle c'est sale oui
c'est le mot de la fin Alexandre allez
vas-y c'est Chabite
comme je disais en fait voilà tant que
notre famille est heureuse c'est
l'essentiel voilà
nos enfants pour nous elle reste on s'en
tape alors et on a entendu égoïste euh
voilà euh rien n'aura
nos enfants on
est heureux ça comment ça se passe
après
bien ce soir vous bossez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]